will celebrate the net the new year with
nextar's Las Vegas countdown to 2023.
here's a look at what you can expect
lists checked Hall's decked but the HoHo
holidays are not over yet hi everyone
I'm Dana Devin and this New Year's Eve
next star's Las Vegas countdown to 2023
is the place to be the three plus hour
party is presented by yamava Resort and
Casino and now from California to Nevada
where to Old Lang Syne
foreign
Resort and Casino let's go get lucky
[Applause]
[Music]
we consider ourselves Southern
California's luxury play and stay
destination from our luxury hotel rooms
to our spa salon our pool to our
restaurant bars lounges are really a
place to come and have a great time from
slots to roulette to Blackjack and
baccarat we're shuffling around the
largest casino in the West
the interesting thing is we've been open
a year now and being open only a year
we're already known for creating
experiences guests that can't get
anywhere else here in here in Highland
California we are living the High Life
want to be a VIP in 2023 this is the
place to be cheers if you are a gambler
this is your kind of place you ready to
have some fun you know it's really fun
you can use your palms rewards here at
yamuba
[Music]
it's very important to tell yamava
customers the story about coming to Las
Vegas and you now have a chance to use
your Club Serrano card and earn the
benefits here at the Palms so you get
both great resorts high above Las Vegas
we are ringing in the new year for every
time zone we are the first Native
American owned and operated Resort
Casino in Las Vegas we received our
gaming license on December 17 2021 and
we opened April 27th
this is Vegas everyone is here to have
fun it's a giant party no matter if
you're at a dinner at a lunch uh late
night whatever
one reason to come to the Palms for New
Year's is we sit above Las Vegas
Boulevard and there's one of the most
amazing fireworks displays anywhere
around the world and you will be able to
see it from above so spend New Year's
Eve with us we have your ticket to it
all double the fun the properties are
only 224 miles apart and don't forget
December 31st double down on fun right
here for nextar's Las Vegas countdown to
2023 cheers